good morning John good morning Hank it's
Friday question Tuesday real questions
from real nerdfighters are there any
foods that you wish were more readily
available in the US no we've got all the
major foods here my major one is paprika
Pringles oh you know what I will say my
wife is a huge fan of hot nuts
Sarah will plan trips to Mexico and then
she will come home with like 400 pounds
of hot nuts and then when you're
crossing through customs do you have any
food and she's like no I mean I don't
think of hot nuts as food exactly we
have this beautiful house and Hank chose
the single corner of the house that is
covered in flies and I when I mentioned
this to him he was like but I already
set it up here hi
oh thanks ma'am hi our next door
neighbor likes our work oh that's so
cool well you'll see this again next
week that's gonna make it I want to ask
academic lovey you okay there I don't
like bees that's all Henry has
nightmares about his bees hell of a
nightmare I'll be like what you dream
about he'll just say be good it's a
healthy healthy fear now that filming
The Fault in Our Stars in Pittsburgh has
started it hasn't it doesn't start until
August 26th will you be coming to
Amsterdam people seem to think that the
movie is being made by me I am just the
author of a book however I think it's
good yeah I am missing it - thanks for
asking I had like really terrible
chronic pain ever since before
Brotherhood 2.0 finally they had to
remove it and do it very complicated and
painful surgery fortunately it does not
hurt anymore as Alliston a nerdfighter
salute yet
alice is one month old she has not made
any intentional gestures of any kind yet
yeah
Henry read in a Berenstein bears book
that sometimes baby sisters bop you on
the nose so he's always like getting his
nose right down next to her arm and
waiting and then and then sometimes
she'll just involuntary in a baby that's
the answer to the question what's the
most adorable story you have ever Hank
what is your favorite game of all time
the game of Thrones I knew it otherwise
stop feeling like I'm not doing anything
with my life there was this guy who is
now in prison his name is Larry Langford
and he was the mayor of my quasi
hometown of Birmingham Alabama and when
he ran for mayor his motto was let's
do something and it turns out that just
doing something is a terrible terrible
idea you don't need to focus on doing
something you need to focus on doing
good things even like very little good
things like doing nice favors for people
you like or something I like that
do you know how dirty your glasses are
no man what is something surprising
you've learned today
uh yeah learned that Hank likes to set
up the camera in places that are covered
in floss a sickle no I did learn
something today I learned that the whole
Chinese monopoly on world silk trade
ended when two guys two monks smuggled
like seven silkworms or something out of
China and took them to the Byzantine
Empire which like completely rewrote
history hey how do you feel out
cucumbers uh give me gas yeah for me
they're just like a step on the way to a
pickle which I hate it's an unrooted but
I certainly like it better than a pickle
you ever considered writing a book with
a pen name it's a good question haven't
I Oh your biggest pet peeve Oh God time
travel were possible where would you go
and why to the present because
antibiotics and when John will you be
back returning Ely not this next Tuesday
when you will see my secret sister
Maureen although she might be me but the
following Tuesday I think it is July
30th we look forward to seeing you then
I look forward to seeing you guys too
I'll see you on July 30th and now oh my
god July 30th it's like a day from
VidCon